congratulations on the success of black
panther how does that feel I mean I know
it was an emotional experience but it
must feel gratifying that it feels
extraordinary you know because if it's a
long 10-month journey to get here but to
finally present the you know all the
hard work to the audience who've been
waiting as well and for it to be
received uh you know as as they have
it's been just great I saw Michael B
Jordan the other night I had a lot of my
home family see what Marvel how you
doing a lot of my family is crazy how
did you guys keep that a secret for as
long as you did see he must he must have
let something out I did well he lied and
said he wasn't in it he told his sister
said that he lied about it see I didn't
lie I just didn't say anything people
asked you were just like
I don't know we're gonna see yeah
especially to my children who I try
never to lie to how will they ever trust
you again I know uh is it true that you
didn't want your character to to die oh
really
you know who wants their mother gone
from them gone very far from them you
don't do you no so you know she's a
beloved I I love playing the queen
finally and also the audiences love the
queen represent their mother also so
Ryan knew what he was doing because the
collected all when that hits you I mean
it's just visceral one when I and many
people saw this film people thought this
is a potential that she could get an
Oscar nomination for this what would
that mean to you I know that's not what
the work is about but what would it mean
if that did happen you know it's been
many years here in this town trying to
do excellent work trying to do good work
carving out a career carving our
consistency
um it would be very very very very very
very nice
Michael J fox being honored tonight oh
do you what was the first time you saw
Michael on screen oh of course the you
know his television show when he was you
know in his salad days when he was a
very young man very pleased for him to
get his award tonight along with the
other honorees us on palsy you know
who's wonderful sugarcane alley and of
course Diane Warren does she not have
many many Oscars already
and and Peter Weir so yeah
congratulations to all the honors
[Music]